salut les épis curieux j'adore faire mon
marché au printemps surtout pour y
acheter
mais fruits et légumes en cette saison
il n'y en a plein qui refont surface
il y en a j'adore en particulier il a
une drôle de tête
la petite caméra nous dit souvent qu'il
me fait tourner la tête
ici on lui faisait tourner la sienne par
la caméra l'artichaut
allez c'est parti on va tourner les
artichauts à l'origine l'artichaut est
un chardon oui oui un chardon un gros
char dont sauvage des traces de ces
chardon ont été retrouvés en suisse dans
des habitations près historique datant
de plus de 2800 nos ancêtres ont
rapidement eu l'idée de cultiver ce
charlot et de sélectionner ceux qui
avaient les plus beaux capitule les plus
belles pièces floral si vous préférez
afin de pouvoir se régaler la date de
ses premières domestication n'est pas
connue mais elle a sans doute eu lieu à
la même époque que la dôme explications
de son cousin le cardon le cardon on en
a parlé dans un précédent sur la planche
puis il semble qu'en europe l'artichaut
soit tombé dans l'oubli mais
heureusement il a survécu du côté
africain de la méditerranée et en
andalousie
d'où il est reparti à la conquête de
l'europe du nord quelques siècles plus
tard il est cultivé en italie à partir
du 15e siècle en france il devient très
populaire un siècle plus tard à l'époque
il est consommé en entre eux mais c'est
à dire entre le fromage et le dessert ou
carrément en dessert l'histoire raconte
d'ailleurs que catherine de médicis en
raffolait tout comme louis xiv
à tel point que le roi soleil aurait
exigé qu'au moins cinq variétés
différentes d'artichaut soient servis à
la table de versailles le blanc le vert
le violet le rouge et le sucre est
peut-être parce qu'ils étaient
recommandés pour le traitement de
l'oedème et de la journée peut-être sauf
que l'artichaut était aussi considérée
comme une plante aphrodisiaques
on rapporte que sur les marchés
parisiens on entendait les marchands les
marchands de crier c'est pas moi qui
l'ait déjà le roi du coup avec peut-être
une idée derrière la tête
cela dit les vertus aphrodisiaques de la
plante n'ont jamais été démontrée plus
sérieusement l'artichaut est riche en
emule in une fibre alimentaire dont se
régalent des bactéries présentes dans
nos intestins
sachez aussi que ce légume contient du
potassium du sodium du magnésium et de
la vitamine b9
autant de bonnes raisons de le mettre au
coeur de nos menus de temps en temps
tiens à ce propos comment le cuisine tôt
la cuisine c'est là bas
aller du plus simple au plus compliqué
l'artichaut peut être cuits en entier
après l'avoir lavée bien sûr et
débarrassé d'une bonne partie ça kitsch
c'est un mode de cuisson qui convient
très bien aux gros artichauts le kamut
bretagne notamment
on les plonge dans l'eau froide et salée
est la tête en bas et encore une petite
demi heure un peu plus s'ils sont
vraiment très en fait quand les feuilles
se détache facilement c'est qu'il est
temps de les manger et l'artichaut ça se
mange archi chaud des artichauts jeu bon
me fait chaud il ne vous reste plus qu'à
les feuillets à déguster la base des
feuilles en a 30 ans dans une vie n'est
qu'à est une source blanche béchamel
objectif atteindre le coeur de
l'artichaut les auparavant il faut
passer l'épreuve du feu
on y est le choeur se trouve juste en
dessous sous le fouet mais de quoi
s'agit-il exactement
pour la changer de crémerie retourne
dans l'atelier pour faire un peu de
botanique le coeur de l'artichaut est en
fait le réceptacle floral de la plante
c'est à dire la partie sur laquelle
viennent s'en crée les fleurs si la tête
de l'artichaut n'est pas accueillie il
en sortira un capitule c'est à dire un
ensemble de petites fleurs violettes un
capitule vous en avez déjà vu si si en
observant de près une pâquerette c'est
son coeur jaune
il est constitué de minuscules fleurs et
c'est ensemble qu'on appelle un capitule
pour l'artichaut c'est la même chose
seulement quand l'artichaut est cueilli
le capitule n'est pas encore mature ils
forment ce que l'on appelle le foie ces
petits poils sont en fait les futurs
fleurs de l'artichaut s'il n'avait pas
été cueilli ses poils se serait
transformé en fleurs quant aux feuilles
que nous raconte avec les dents ce ne
sont pas des feuilles mais les bractées
des pièces floral chargés de protéger la
fleur au passage c'est sûrement ce
légume est ce mode de cuisson qui est à
l'origine de l'expression avoir un coeur
d'artichaut qui signifie tombé amoureux
facilement on le dit d'une personne dont
on peut facilement atteindre le coeur
comme celui d'un artichauts allez les
petits coeurs on retourne en cuisine
si on ne veut manger que le coeur de
l'artichaut il faut le tourner
mais non le tourner sur lui même
je vous montre et tiens je vous lance en
même temps un petit défi essayez vous
aussi de faire tourner un artichaut
évitement commentaires si vous avez
réussi et à quel point c'était facile ou
non vous êtes prêts allez c'est parti
[Musique]
et voilà un joli coeur d'artichaut rien
pour vous pour varier les plaisirs
l'artichaut se prépare aussi à la coque
en coupant les feuilles à mi-hauteur les
variétés plus petite violette peuvent
quant à elles se mangent et poêlée
quelques minutes ou même cru en salade
avec une bonne huile d'olive avec les
artichauts
on n'a que l'embarras du choix en fait
il ya presque autant de recettes de
préparation que de variétés
allez petit inventaire en france le
catalogue officiel des variétés
d'artichaut en répertorie 11
on les trouve sur les étals du printemps
à l'automne
vous en connaissez sûrement certain que
le gros ver 2 l'an le violet de provence
qu'on appelle poivrade quand il est tout
petit le cardinal le calicot et bien sûr
le camus de bretagne vers et de lui
c'est l'artichaut le plus consommé en
france 75 % de la production française
est comme son nom l'indiqué il vient de
bretagne la plus grosse région
productrice d'artichaut avec le
roussillon je t'adore gamin
je t'adore excusez le il est un peu dur
de la feuille mais il a bon coeur allez
à très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
et d'ici là
régalez vous si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus merci les épis curieux pour les
plus gourmands en voici d'autres et pour
ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Applaudissements]